uh thank you for that introduction so
once again i'm i'm james eaves i'm an
agricultural economist
and professor at laval university in the
business school
um a few years ago i started uh i
started
a research project with university and
two companies
green seal cannabis company and volt
server
and following that experiment i worked
as green seals
uh head of r d for nearly two years
and then last week in fact i joined
um i left green i left green sale at the
beginning of the year and last week i
joined
um volt server as their indoor
agricultural director
so i just want just for the sake of
transparency i wanted to
share my my uh links with you
professional links with you um second
i'd like to
apologize um typically i'm i
i invest more in preparing for
presentations but as you know it's a
special time
last week our university gave us one
week to convert
all our courses to online courses and so
i've been overwhelmed with that
um and i haven't had as much time as i
would have liked
have to practice and prepare for this
presentation um so it might be a little
less fluid than i would like
um i just so i'd like to begin
um by just sharing in our
perspective about the history of our
culture with you and i say
a perspective because there's lots of
perspectives and um
i'd like to share one with you regarding
how
agriculture is on this continuous since
this
advent is on this continuous um trend
towards increasing amounts of control
over garment and the plant
um for instance the transition of humans
um going out into the wild to gather the
food
to actually farming to actually creating
plots of land where they
grow the food they want and attempt to
manipulate that environment
was perhaps a single biggest um increase
in control
um that we've seen and it's all that
periods often referred to or is referred
to as the first agricultural
revolution and overall we've seen these
other
discrete jumps and control that have
resulted in these enormous
um improvements in the quality of
unstandard living for humanity
for instance uh irrigation and
and improve the invention of greenhouses
um gave humans a much greater
control over the environment in which
the plants grew
whereas starting in the early 20th
century
the ability to actually create hybrid
plants and and to genetically modify
plants allowed us to control
how plants responded to particular
environments or to enable plants to grow
in environments that they wouldn't
otherwise be able to
now at the same time both so there's
this
incredible value to control you see that
being able to control the environment
but that value isn't constant over over
across time and it isn't constant across
crops in other words at different
periods in time
um the value of being able to control
our growing environment is higher or
lower
just in the same way our for different
crops our value
for being able to control the
environment or those plants adds
different value
and that and that that value
um greatly depends
on consumer preferences and i so i'd
like to give you
a sense of what i mean and examples of
how consumer preferences
impact the value of being able to
control growing environments
using two examples cut flowers
and tomatoes and there's a typo here
it's not a little flower it should be
cut flowers and tomatoes
so the cut flower industry
um really began in the 1600s
and at the time there are three main
varieties of flowers
and they were grown in um
in north america and northern europe
which aren't necessarily ideal
environments for growing flowers
so during this period greenhouses really
flourished as
as the main technology for
growing um these flowers
um but something
something important happened in the 20th
century in the beginning of 20th century
was the invention of refrigerated trucks
and ships um and what that allowed
people to do is actually
grow those flowers pretty much anywhere
in the world and then ship them to the
markets
so at that point um these flowers just
grew
this production just shifted to parts of
the world
um that had the low had these kind of
ideal environments
for growing any one of those three
varieties
for the lowest uh unit cost of
production so
europe for europe the european market
the market
the cultivation generally shifted to
africa
um and in the u.s it first shifted out
west
from the east coast of the united states
first to colorado
and then to california yeah um and then
when trade routes opened or
certain trade negotiations um
established
um that production shifted to south
america
now but there's but there's this
interesting trend that always happens
um for products in like free market or
capitalist
societies is that consumers generally
always
look for new experiences new product and
service experiences
we see that with cars with cereals we
see it with everything
and the same thing happened with flowers
you know rather than
um essentially humans people consumers
got bored with
carnations and bouquets of carnations
and roses and they wanted more variety
and versus today there are at least 60
different types of varieties of cut
flowers demanded by consumers
and consumer producers of course how to
respond
to that that demand for variety
and variety and experiences and variety
in flowers by producing those flowers
but each of these flowers or many of
these flowers demand
or require different types of
environments right so
it was easier more cost effective to
provide
those those those environments in
greenhouses where it was easier to
con to control the humidity or the
temperature or the amount of light
that these plants received so when this
specialty cut flower market evolved it
reinvigorated the greenhouse market
and so we saw greenhouses growing
flowers again
in places like amsterdam amsterdam and
california
um and we saw a very similar pattern
with tomatoes it's people are often
surprised to hear
that california which is one of the most
important producers of
tomatoes in the world actually imports
tomatoes from canada that's it it's if
you know anything about tomatoes it's
really surprising because
tomatoes are a plant that likes warm
environments and one of the most
light um and one of the plants that
demand that one of the crops that demand
the most amount of light
whereas canada is typically cold
um and and has has relatively little
light compared to other parts of the
world
but what happened was during we saw a
similar trend that we saw with flowers
before the teas there were a small
number of varieties
of tomatoes that consumers demanded but
during the 80s
the whole heirloom uh tomato trend
started and and suddenly
consumers discovered wow these are like
these there's there's
there's more variety in the sort of the
the taste
experience of of with with tomatoes
and so they started increasing a
a demand increasing number of varieties
of tomatoes
so it became profitable
right to start growing tomatoes and
greenhouses where i could
create all these different environments
to produce optimally produce these
different varieties
of of tomatoes and there was no reason
why some
greenhouses wouldn't function in
california as plenty of light and they
could
they could take advantage of that light
and create these different environments
in um in california
but control also requires energy
it requires electricity even in
california
to grow tomatoes year-round you would
have to supplement
you would have to supplement the light
with electric light and you would have
with a electric lighting you would have
to
and and use um electricity to try to
modify
the environment uh but in ca and and
because of
electricity regulation california
electricity prices are
really high whereas in in canada
electricity prices
are relatively low and so production of
tomatoes
of those these specialty varieties
shifted to the place where it was most
cost
effective um to basically buy that
control
like basic sophisticated greenhouses
that had supplemental
lighting and today if you look at
california
90 of tomatoes are grown outdoors and
less than 10 are grown in greenhouses
whereas exactly the opposite is true in
canada
90 of tomatoes are grown indoors and
greenhouses
and 10 percent are grown outdoors
and today canada i think is the most
important
exporter of of tomatoes in north america
at the same time at the same time
these uh greenhouses still have
challenges with control for instance
this is a quote from a large
ornamental grower who says that we have
like we have soda crops we have so many
different varieties we have to produce
and each of those varieties require a
different
environment and our biggest challenge is
providing
um is customizing the environment for
those various
varieties
so what i just want to gain from this
sort of historical perspective is the
fact that
when we look across markets right say
the markets for fruits and vegetables or
when the demand for variety is low
we see that it's worth it like if the if
the market only demands
three types of tomatoes or three types
of flowers
if it's possible to trade and ship those
produce which
would which it is we'll just look across
the world
find the extensive ideal environment to
grow these things grow them at scale and
ship them where we ship them
but when demand is high and
consumers want to try a different tomato
every week or have different types of
bouquets of flowers
then the value of control increases
significantly
and you'll see farmers or farmers should
be making investments
into technology that enables them to
customize
environments and change those
environments as
as as demand shifts rapidly
for each of those varieties
no so what does it have to do with
cannabis
there's this really fascinating
real world experiment that's happening
with in the
in the world of agriculture centered
with cannabis centered on cannabis right
now
for the first time in history you see
two types of technologies for growing a
plant in a controlled environment
essentially competing we have
greenhouses
right and simultaneously we have indoor
farms
greenhouse growers are
making the bet that that the
amount of control you with a greenhouse
is enough given that
given that given that they can offset
their electricity costs by
by by replacing at least some
artificial light with sunlight right
they're making the bed that that's the
most the greenhouse is the most
profitable strategy giving
given those factors whereas indoor
farmers
are making the bet that the market
will puts us a sufficient
value on control right that
actually growing um in an indoor
environment where i can
have safely higher levels of control um
over the environment
is the most profitable strategy now i'm
not
just as it stands it's not clear
even though i've been talking about the
value of control um
it's quite possible that the indoor farm
is just
it's just it's just too much too early
in that
given the pr cap price of lights and
price electricity and price of equipment
um the market's not ready to pay for
that level of control
again it's going to depend on on
consumers demand for the cost of that
equipment of course
how what's the additional value
um in terms of the the quantity
and quality of the product that i
produce um
what's the additional the what what's
the additional value
i can think that i can produce
with this increase in in control
um and
and the fact is i would say for
being involved in this industry for a
long time um
that the vast majority of people in this
industry
think that it's a no-brainer that um
that indoor growing is just an artifact
of the illegal market or prohibition
when growers basically had to hide
their farms and that now that growers
can
grow out in the open it makes perfect
sense that they would reduce their
their variable costs by leveraging
the quote unquote free value or free
energy from the sun
um this is these are quotes from a 2017
special edition of marijuana business
magazine
and essentially every single expert
interviewed in for that for that article
agreed that that
it's just a matter of time before
greenhouses supplant
um indoor farms um there was just i
i participated in this interview also i
was the only one
um that believed that it wasn't so clear
that i actually believed that
indoor farms would um
out compete greenhouses for the high-end
campus market and the reason that
i felt that way that just prior to that
article about two years before
that article was published um a
co-author and i
conducted a detailed analysis comparing
the profitability of growing lettuce
in a greenhouse versus growing lettuce
in a in
a vertical farm in quebec and the reason
we chose quebec
was because it's a place that has
relatively little light compared to
other places
and inexpensive electricity has some of
the cheapest electricity in north
america
so if if growing in if if it
if it wasn't more profitable to grow or
or at least competitive to grow in a
vertical farm and get back
then basically it would be nowhere in
north america
and for this study what we did if we
made certain
important assumptions we assumed that
light levels were the same in other
words
regardless if you're growing in a
greenhouse or in your farm
um there was a certain level of light
was achieved in both if in
if it was straightforward how we do in a
vertical farm we just have
electric powered lighting or artificial
lighting
and but in the greenhouse if we don't
have enough light
we the farmer would have to add
additional light using supplemental
lighting
and so we made that assumption that
electricity is the same but that
the total amount of light the dli the
daily light integral
is the same um
and we also assumed that um the quality
of the product was the same and the way
we did that is we we assume that both
technologies the indoor farm and the uh
the greenhouse
um neither use an hvac system right
neither had
um air conditioning and dehumidification
the
greenhouse um the indoor farm cooled and
dehumidified
managed humidity um by using vents and
fans
right there's no reason there's no
reason typically indoor farms don't do
that but there's no reason they can't
um we could have equivalently we could
have said oh we forced the
the greenhouse to use an hvac system
that was just a way to make it
come in an apple apples comparison if we
don't make that assumption
then the indoor farm has a more
controlled environment
and between a higher quality product or
higher yields
um and so we wouldn't be able to isolate
the impact of
basically light right on a sunlight on
the cost structure
of a greenhouse
um sorry excuse me and what we found was
that
because the indoor farm was well
insulated
and the greenhouse wasn't and the indoor
farm was able to use space more
efficiently because you could stack
keep plants closer together and stack um
stacked plants have you have a vertical
farm have multiple levels of plants
um that the greenhouse used
significantly more heating
energy to heat their greenhouse and they
had a higher real estate cost because
they
took up more and that made the vertical
lettuce farm
at least as profitable as a greenhouse
in quebec
um now that was a pretty stunning
result and
and it was it's interesting because we
used
lettuce as our model and as many of you
know
lettuce does not require tremendous
amounts of light
um so for many likes
for several months of the year actually
the light that's provided by the sun
is enough to provide lettuce with
the required minimal amount of light
that it needs in quebec
we talk about plants that
take up that need significantly more
light
right for instance cannabis or tomatoes
then the contribution of
sunlight to
the total amount that of light that the
plant needs is less
right so the value of the sunlight
declines in other words
and say in in california
over the entire year um
the sun in a greenhouse provides 30
units called of light
and the plant uh that would be perfectly
fine for lettuce you would even have to
shade it for lettuce you wouldn't need
any
supplemental lighting but for cannabis
say cannabis needs 50 or 60 units of
light
then the sun provides a smaller
proportion
of the total amount of light that the
plant needs
so you'd have to add supplemental light
to grow the plant optimally
in other words as the demand for light
increases the plant's demand for light
increases the relative contribution of
sun
of the sun decreases um
so to give you a sense
so i did a kind of back of the envelope
analysis
for growing
cannabis in a greenhouse and my
objective here with this back of the
envelope analysis was just to give you a
sense
of what is how much does
using the sun decrease my electricity
cost
when i'm when i'm growing cannabis is it
is it an enormous amount that makes it
really exciting to grow
cannabis in a greenhouse or a less
exciting amount
now in order to do this i have to make
certain assumptions
first i assume that 65 percent
of the sun's light actually hits the
plants
in other words some percentage
of the sun is going to reflect off the
surface
of the the glass house the surface of
the green
um so i made assumptions 35 of the sun's
light
reflects off the off the greenhouse and
the rest
actually penetrates a greenhouse and
hits the plants it's actually a
um it's a very optimistic amount of
of light since that might be true when
you first build a greenhouse but
pretty rapidly there's dust there's dirt
there's residuals from
from residue from from water and that
reduces
that efficiency level second assumption
i make is that
the led efficiency is 1.5
micro moles per joule in other words it
takes
in order to produce like 1.5 unit light
it takes one joule of electricity so the
bigger that number the more efficient
the led is at
at converting electricity into photons
i mean that's actually kind of low for
leds for the
today's leds um and just to back up here
so what i'm
what i'm going to show you in the next
slide or i'm going to try to do is
actually
imagine try to estimate
how many watts of light how many
by allowing sunlight to come into my
greenhouse
um how many leds can i get rid of
right how many leds does it displace
right and so that's why these
assumptions are important
now i'm like the lettuce like the
lettuce
farm uh or the lesson now system also
assume that
both greenhouse and the indoor farm um
have the same climate control so either
they both have hvac or they don't
right so that way i don't have to worry
about the quality of the plant
um and finally the value of the cannabis
is six dollars per gram
um so this is the this is the result so
i did this for different regions from
relatively dark regions to regions with
lots of sunlight
um so you see in quebec or british
columbia
there's not a lot of sunlight compared
to other parts of north america
so on average having a greenhouse
in quebec or bc um
and allowing sun into the greenhouse
right is equivalent to having 150 watt
led light over 4x4 that's how much light
the sun is providing it allows me to
take not use
150 watts or reduce the total amount
of watts use to light my plants like
my 4x4 1.5 meter square table
i'm buying watts as i move to sunnier
places
like colorado has much more sun than
quebec
now i'm able to remove 300 more watts
of led lights where and i
if i go to a very sunny place like
phoenix
arizona you see at the bottom i can
remove 400 watts of light a much
a much larger uh bulb i get rid of and
so the value of the light
is you see is increasing now i calc
i estimated i used the average
commercial electricity price
for each of these regions the cap to
calculate or estimate
the value of that electric electricity
again per four by four table
or like per a 16 foot square foot table
or 1.5 meter square table which is a
typical
table size in this industry
so you see in quebec where energy prices
are very low
um and there's not much light so the sun
is not actually not it's not displacing
that much light
the value of the light that i'm getting
from the sun
is about two dollars and seventy one
cents per month
per four by four cable and that's
actually about 30 too high because i
forgot to convert that to us
dollars that for that 271 is actually
canadian dollars whereas the rest of the
tables in u.s dollars
um whereas if i go to phoenix where
there's lots of light
so i'm able to remove 400 watts of light
from my farm
that's equivalent to reducing my
electricity costs by 11.44
per month per 4x4 table
of course lights can be expensive and so
i also
calculated the monthly cost of owning
um an led light i assume that the led
light costs two dollars
per watt which is an expensive
horticulture light
um and that you pay monthly
for this light over ten years um because
the life
the expected life span of these lights
is about 10 years
so you see that again by the the quebec
light is a relatively inexpensive light
it's about three dollars and uh 49 cents
per month
whereas a phoenix light which is a much
larger light is about nine dollars and
32 cents
so the question is like for instance in
phoenix a very bright place
uh lots of sunlight i'm i'm removing i'm
saving about 20
a month in cost related to
lighting by having a greenhouse right
but if we look at
the that percentage of revenues in terms
of how much that that cost as a
percentage of the revenues created on
that four by four table
we see that it's very small right from
it ranges from quebec which is about
point two percent
of revenues um to
say northern california that are
expensive electricity to about still
less than one percent
of revenues so you're giving up
control of the environment
um and we'll i haven't we haven't talked
about what's the value of that control
yet but we have some controlled
environment because
a greenhouse certainly offers less
control than indoor farm for instance
if i'm in a greenhouse and suddenly
clouds
um uh clouds come over and block the
sunlight my my
vpd is going to drop rapidly um
if i explain when it starts getting warm
in california or
back in and growers and events and
greenhouses it just sucks out because
it's windy it sucks out the humidity
from the greenhouse and shocks the
plants
so there is a can there are costs
to giving up control can be indoor farm
um and in exchange for those losses in
control
you're really just reducing your
um your costs from anywhere from point
two percent
of revenues to point seven percent of or
point eight percent percent of revenues
and there is strong evidence
that i say not strong i'll say there's
evidence suggests that growing indoors
um does like the market does value
the increased control provided by
growing indoors
for instance cannabis benchmarks is this
agency that tracks wholesale
cannabis prices across the united states
and canada
and consistently they find that cannabis
grown
indoors the wholesale price of canada's
cannabis grown indoors is about 40
percent higher
than cannabis grown in greenhouses and
there's several reasons why that might
be
but one explanation is that it's simply
better that because
the market has determined that cannabis
grown indoors for whatever reason is
higher
quality and so worth more money i've
done my own survey
of retailers in canada and found
a very similar result that in canada
also
cannabis grown indoors is is
sold for a higher price and cannabis
grown in greenhouses
i'd argue that
even given
the incredible opportunity of
opportunities presented by
higher levels of control and indoor farm
today's growers are rarely taking
advantage of it indoor growers are
leveraging just a fraction
of the benefits of potential benefits of
higher control
i think today they typically use
indoor farms to provide more harvest per
year
and to create a more consistent
environment
which from the previous slide you see
that that maybe that's that's
provides or create generates a lot of
value
um but the potential benefits are go
much farther than that
for instance one of the benefits i think
are
most important it's just the benefits of
higher levels of
our ability the ability to do more
controlled experiments
for instance because i have a
a more uh enclosed environment an indoor
farm
i can have and i can have multiple like
different rooms
inside that same indoor farm i can
create different environments i can
essentially
do more or less controlled experiments
so i can learn faster about what the
optimal
conditions are for each plant and after
i learn that
information i can actually customize the
environment and maintain the environment
for
multiple varieties and as we discussed
earlier we saw in different for the
tomato flower market the more varieties
there are the higher
the benefits of actually being able to
provide those customized environments
and finally it's a more uh
it's a more appropriate
uh environment for developing new
hybrids by being able to control
the environment right i can i can not
only
uh it's not any more conducive
developing
new types of plants um
but it also allows me to
find plants look around the world and
find plants that aren't necessarily
don't necessarily grow well in my
environment and create
an environment an optimal environment
for them here
and wherever you're located um so not
only is it about developing new hybrids
but taking hybrids from
from from different parts of the world
and instead of
changing the genetics of the plant it
gives us the ability to change the
environment around the plant
um and so there's in other words it
creates options
right the having and better control the
environment creates
options and people who are familiar with
finance there's something called
option value and so when i have more
options that the optionality generates
tremendous amounts of value
and as we mentioned the value of being
able to
like learn and customize environments
increases with demand for variety if
there was just one variety
demanded by consumers then that's then
the the value of learning and customized
environments is very low but there's
just lots of varieties it increases
an interesting thing about cannabis is
there's tremendous amounts of varieties
there's at least 1 000 different
cultivars
and the plant has
extremely rich chemical profile that
we're just starting to understand
um what the implications of that profile
and if you
if and and an interesting thing about
having a plant where the chemical
profile
is important to the consumer is that
small changes in the environment that
the plant grows in can have a
significant impact on that chemical
profile so it becomes valuable to be
able to identify
that environment and provide it for the
plan
so so still i want
in the last part of this presentation i
want to give you a sense of
what in fact or gives
is the value of control and so now i
want to go back to this original
experiment that i alluded to at the
beginning of the presentation
um and what we did is we asked well
the easiest thing or the biggest
differential between
between an indoor grower and a
greenhouse or an outdoor grower
is the fact that indoor growers have
more control for lighting
right they can provide whatever lighting
they want
so with three partners
laval university
a cultivator greenhouse cannabis a
greenhouse cannabis which is this
exceptional grower
in canada they have a great uh
reputation
um across the country they have they won
best grower
top grower in canada last year they were
also a magazine
identified them as having the highest
strain of uh the highest teach producing
the string with the highest thc
in the country um so they're an
excellent partner to work with
um volt server is actually an
intelligent buildings company
what they do is they um
they provide what's essentially it's
called it's called digital electricity
it's
um i'm not it's just i'm i'm not trying
to plug the company it's just a
really innovation it's basically high
high voltage electricity you can touch
like so once basically you just connect
conventional electricity to the from the
street
but then everything inside all the
wiring inside anyone can do
it right electrician because it's
literally a new type of electricity
that's safe to touch i won't get
into how it's done but that's that's a
fact
but then the other thing about it is it
simultaneously can transmit data
and so it's used by it's been used by
intelligent buildings
to basically connect everything in their
building so if they wanted like their
their last
installation was for hilton hotels and
um they they enabled the first
intelligent hotel
in uh in the united states and what it
what basically they allowed so basically
you walk in
and the sensor sense who's in the room
they remember who you are
they remember that the the lighting
adjusts automatically the music that you
like comes on the
water chapter changes automatically and
as you like change these things it
remembers it's basically learning how
it's gathering the data
to customize um the environment for the
person
in that hotel room and so um
and so they basically provided the
analytics
and electricity distribution and
lighting as well that before they
sourced the lighting from
this it's just a flood light they
sourced a very powerful flood light from
china
um to help us with this study and
what we did was we basically we went and
um several of the leading manufacturers
of horticulture lights participated as
well
and so we took a broad range of life
about i think there were eight different
types of lights and they all had
different intensities and all had
different spectrums
and we basically just grew plants under
them and we did it for
a long period of time several harvests
um
and what we want we're measuring yields
and
thc and so you can actually see you see
all this different they're all different
spectrums
um in the back you can actually see um
some hps lights with hps and led
and but we also wanted to experiment
with levels of
light intensity that were much higher
than
levels that are of light that are
typically provided by
horticulture lights because you know
this is the first time this was
actually the first kind of large
lighting experiment done
um by an academic institution and so we
just because hbs provides a certain
amount of light and everyone's always
use hps there's no study that suggests
that's the proper amount of light
so we went and bought floodlights that
provided much more light
so we can see what actually is the
optimal amount of light
for plants for cannabis plants
and what we found was really dramatic
basically on the bottom axis of the
graph is light intensity
and on the vertical axis is
yields per 4x4 yields per 1.5 meters
squared
and if you look in if you look at the
bottom where you see about
800 that's the ppfd
of 800 um that's about a typical
um double-ended hps light provides about
between 800 and 900
ppfd um or units of light was let's just
say
per 4x4 and most you see a big clump of
li of light intensities around that
because most leds
try to be provide as this basically the
same amount of light as
hps but with using less energy
the that the little bubble at the
extreme right
of this graph is just a
a high intensity flood light just
basically general purpose
led flood light it's made for the street
um and what this shows you and that in
that amount of light provides about
twice the amount the
amount of light as say an hps
double-ended hps
and what this shows you is there's this
very strong linear relationship
between light intensity and yields
regardless of light regardless of the
spectrum
i increase light intensity i increase
yields up to
twice the amount of light provided by
the typical horticulture light um
another thing you see is like all
bubbles are kind of like
around along that line which means that
the spectrum
is not influencing that relationship in
other words sometimes lights are sold as
having
a special spectrum and that does
wonderful things
um but what this shows you is just that
in terms of yields
it's just light intensity that matters
um
and to put things in perspective we
basically
during the courses experiment we
increase yields
per plant by between 30 to 100 percent
depending on the cultivar
um by providing much more light
than 99 of the industry
provides to their plants
so that's a tremendous amount of money
it turns out a revenue generated by just
learning right being able to experiment
with lighting
and learning the right amount of light
to provide to plants
and the reason i'm saying this is that
that intelligent lighting is just one
factor
there's so much to learn about there's
there's irrigation there's temperature
there's air flow
there's there's the temperature of of
the root zone there's it just goes on
and on it's like sometimes when i'm i'm
doing this research like oh my gosh
i have to check that also we have
there's so many things to check
but what the intelligent lighting this
example shows you
is that there is tremendous value
to learning um
what is the osmo conditions for the
plant and then manipulating the
environment to provide
um those conditions right
and it's what i'm saying is that doing
that
indoors right doing that in a closed
environment
is much it's much more suitable to do
and
and efficient to do that in a closed
environment than doing that outdoors or
in a greenhouse
right um
so just to conclude
i so there's i'm i'm arguing that this
is
tremendous value that's to that
that's going to be unlocked unrelated to
agriculture that's that's been enabled
by this advent of indoor farms
that's that that was enabled by
legalization of cannabis um i don't at
this point in time i don't think indoor
growers
are are looking at value but they will
because
there's tremendous variety demanded by
consumers
in the cannabis market and they want to
try something new
every week right and that variety is
going to drive
producers to technologies that enable
them to supply that variety
in the most effective and efficient way
possible
so i so i believe that five years from
now
we're going to see that the leaders in
this market are not necessarily the
leaders today
but they're the leaders that are making
an investment into this intelligent
agriculture or intelligent farming today
and what's really exciting is that this
is not gonna this is not just for the
cannabis market these these technologies
and methods
that we're gonna learn in cannabis
market because the higher margins in
cannabis
enable those investments are
are those the cost of those technologies
and methods can be driven down by the
scale of the industry
and it's going to make those those
methods and technology
available to for other crops like
tomatoes
cucumbers lettuce whatever
and that's going to fundamentally change
controlled
agriculture controlled environment
agriculture
growing in controlled environments
and i strongly believe that what's that
this is this is a new revolution
in our culture that we're seeing unfold
and that over the
next five to ten years we're going to
see indoor farming
initially soon rapidly
disrupt large proportions of the
greenhouse market
um so once again if that was less fluid
than would like it was definitely less
fluid than i would have liked i
apologize
like as we said this time so i i know
that you guys are all
compassionate um and i thank you and i'm
happy
be very happy to um meet you virtually
and to answer your questions so thanks
again for your time and thank you
approvation